hello grammarians hello paige hi david
so today we're going to talk about
identifying subjects and predicates and
in order to do that we shall begin with
a sentence page would read me the
sentence please i bought a crate of
goblin hats thank you paige
so do you think that's like hats
for goblins or hats that make you look
like a goblin
um well i bought it so i can say that it
is both
so we could go either way it's what
you're saying
oh yeah so a sentence is kind of like a
car it's got a lot of different parts
right like an engine or wheels or a body
whatever
a sentence is very much the same way and
you can divide up a sentence into parts
and so today we're going to be dividing
up the sentence into subject and
predicate paige what is the subject of a
sentence so the subject is a noun or a
pronoun
that
is doing the action in the sentence or
performing the verb
what does that mean to perform a verb
right so a verb isn't always an action
right that's why i wanted to clarify
because you can say like i am happy and
am is a verb but
that's not like an action that i'm doing
right you can't just actively am right
but in this sentence i am happy the
subject i is performing the verb to be
or am right gotcha what is a predicate
so a predicate is kind of all of the
rest of the sentence that isn't the
subject so what it really is is like the
verb and all of its
all of the parts that are related to the
verb yeah verb and it's pals that's good
so let's apply that approach to goblin
hat sentence so okay so i'm looking for
a noun or pronoun that performs a verb
in the sentence well i found the verb
and the verb is bought who's doing the
buying i am so our subject is i yeah
and then predicate
is basically everything else right so
it's bought what did i buy a crate of
goblin hats right
so you can see that a crate of goblin
hats is also a noun right but it's not
doing anything in the sentence i am
buying so just because there's a noun
just because there's another noun in the
sentence like crate or goblin hats
doesn't necessarily mean that it's the
subject right so you have to look for
the thing that is performing the verb
exactly so i think paige i think that
covers everything except
exactly what a goblin hat is but we can
talk about that some other time yeah so
that's identifying subjects and
predicates you can learn anything dave
it out page out